how do you practice self-care without
feeling selfish aha well here's my pithy
answer and then maybe we can we can talk
about a little bit Randy my pithy answer
is self-care and selfish reside on
opposite sides of our values I tend to
look at I look at cell operating water
in one's own self-interest which is self
care is different from self ish which is
operating to the detriment of other
people yeah how do you differentiate
selfishness from self care brushing your
teeth metaphor so um it's where you
brush your teeth never heard of okay
okay no like okay brushing your teeth is
something you do every day and you
benefit from it and the people around
you benefit from it right and so do you
feel guilty for brushing your teeth do
you feel like you're being selfish like
this is really a new like a great way of
approaching these acts of self care is
it something that you need to do to
benefit yourself and it benefits those
around you and you can't feel from an
empty cup right so so I say my pity
answer is self care is a daily brushing
of the mind body and how dare you come
on here now shut up leave that out make
her Pitt the answer say we could do a
whole podcast about feed my pet the
answer is to give your best to others
you must first give your best to
yourself and just to Josh's point as a
self-care it only becomes selfish when
it is a detriment to others that's what
you need to look at if you are doing
something for yourself and it's making
someone else miserable then maybe you
want to look at that and be like am I
being selfish right now but
sometimes sometimes here's here's kind
of the tricky part right sometimes it's
self-care that we do it does piss other
people off and they have poor expect so
we've got to be able to differentiate
when someone has a poor expectation or
if we're the ones that have the poor
expectation so that's again easier said
than done
like most of the stuff we talked about
but but the more you practice it the
better you get at it for sure the
interesting thing about that too is
sometimes self-care is a really really
hard decision like the the more you
develop a relationship with yourself and
I call it your inner wisdom it it can
sometimes guide you down paths that are
really hard so it could be you know
getting a divorce
yeah you know moving to a new place
that's that's also self-care so it's we
have to be ready to to maybe make some
tough calls sometimes yeah yeah I think
quite often the expectation thing can be
can be so tricky because we don't want
to let other people down right but if
I'm letting if I'm if I'm fulfilling
other people's expectations by letting
myself down that's why I have that bet
that list of my own sort of self-care
these are all individual acts that's a
really good point so if you are meeting
others people's expectations but it's
letting yourself down like that that's a
problem right and in a weird way that is
that's an involuted kind of selfishness
when we're operating only on the behalf
of others dude I was trying to come up
with the pithy answer something similar
to that because the the it's selfish to
not take care of yourself in a way I
think it's what you're trying to say
yeah yeah in a weird way it's it's
pacifying others by forsaking the things
that are most important to you and it's
easy to do that because we get this
little dopamine rush when we please
other people and we all are people
pleasers to a certain extent but I've
realized that you mean you you guys both
so for those of you who don't know Randy
and and Ryan they're the same person
actually the first time I've ever I've
only seen them in the same in the same
room one since right now I'm actually
shocked you're not the same person
but they have the same personality and
identical personalities and same sense
of humor and and and I don't know what's
going on right now they were doing like
the et finger no I was double tapping
her oh you like her I got it we're the
same person what were you gonna say
there was just gonna say that I don't
know where I was going with that
honestly
you